I was gonna say for you like uh
you've gotten into this new space where
you're a media personality right yeah so
it's different
um for you I'm sure being on camera all
day yeah way different
um have you
because you obviously represent what you
represent and you also are on camera
every day so have you
like what has been the adjustment for
you to be like okay I have to still be
who I am but I also want to be a
professional and grow within this new
world that I'm getting into because at
the end of the day
you see that there is a very uh
lucrative
is is gold at the content right yeah I
mean you see A.D and and and Tyrell left
and they're doing well yeah you know I
know Adam doesn't want that yeah but
they're doing well and they think yeah
so it's like there's obviously like this
is like a new a new frontier for you so
like how are you adjusting
being you unapologetically and represent
what you represent while also
being a professional because I think you
did it pretty well in the Snoopy badass
thing that I saw yeah well I'm
dedicating all my time to this like
is at a certain point you gotta
hit a grow grow spurt and understand the
growth spurt like sometimes people grow
and they don't understand it like I mean
or like we go through things like
I literally damn near lost it all this
year and got it back off of just doing
this you get what I'm saying when the
whole time I've been out here scrambling
trying to figure out all right decide
this I'm trying to figure out the music
yeah yeah like no I'm talking about the
streets probably appreciate it yeah yeah
but but the music too you hear what I'm
saying like it's just like you play 150
and one foot out no that's what I want
to do this is what I want to do but you
not giving
they sit on the side they could
almost pay you quadruple or a hundred
times more depending on how much work
you put in you're not giving this no
attention so sometimes it got to be like
took from out your face so you can focus
on one thing and and and like when you
see that
you kind of like chosen for this space
and people kind of [__] with you in this
place and they're like yeah I mean if
you'll be a fool not to capitalize off
of what you got going on and not just
give it y'all yeah I would say like
you've done a really good job like I
always I I told this to Adam I was like
what I like about brick baby he's you're
like a really measured guy
on camera yeah yeah yeah like I'm I'm
too calm like him yelling and just
agreeing with I told him what was not
about to happen in the interview who
wins out of that right because
I think like a lot of people would be
like you know because when I when I when
the one that's what I I told Adam the
same [__] I was like bro brick baby's
like very naturally like I think I text
you too like yo you're really good at
this [__] yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you
did you know like I think I would like
to see you just do more like one-on-one
[__] yeah that's what I that's what I'm
uh
that's why I'm at no jumper though
because I'm learning from somebody
that's like one of the best like and I
you can say what you want but like when
you line up the best podcasters and I'm
learning from some one of the top dogs
in the program
and it's like I don't know how to like
if I just jump on and just if the break
baby from when I started going viral and
seeing the internet was [__] with me
and all that [__]
if I was to just start asking somebody
questions on camera
I wouldn't have it written there I
wouldn't be I would just be having the
conversation and I wouldn't know which
way to swing [__] into you give it
upstairs I think you just gotta learn
it's just like a combo it's like yeah
yeah you know it's a convo but
what type of combo because I could have
any type of difference
which is hilarious you get what I'm
saying yes so it's like I gotta for me
it takes me to separate and learn how to
I think just just be on one type of time
you know what I'm saying so once I get
myself together there's nothing you
could tell me like we sitting right here
had you want to do anything else I don't
even got it yet we don't gotta yeah you
just get to it ain't no point in doing
all the Barking right like it ain't no
point of that and I also think like it's
important to understand like hey man
we're we're grown now like we already
like if you you've sat down you've done
everything you need to do at what point
in time do you what do you have to prove
to anybody like I'd rather
as a black in the streets or just saying
you from the streets they're gonna test
you to the day you die 100 I've ever for
the blacks like
other people yeah I grow up and not like
that but [__] understands like
we're grown man it's interesting because
it's almost like people get angry at you
if you're mature if you mature past the
the the obvious
immaturity that is comes with the same
culture strange the street [__] if you
think about it is extremely it's like an
immature lifestyle right you're supposed
to be extremely reactive to things that
Mo normal people wouldn't be reactive to
and it's like yo if I already got
through that part of my life and I'm
still here and I don't know yo I'm I'm
growing up now like like yeah what the
[__] it and it's like I saw people
giving Jeezy [__] because like he was
like the bigger man with the Gucci [__]
I don't know man Jesus Jeezy sold out
I'm like what did you want Jeezy to do
that you you want Jeezy to not wear a
suit and go do a podcast and write a
book and like it's like you you know I
mean
he went over whatever he was gonna do
but at the end of the day wake up
supposed to fight the [__] for the
world right there and Gucci Gucci's come
out and said he kind of regretted how he
handled that yeah yeah so it's like at
the end of the day because Gucci feel
like a kid his girl told him you you
kind of yeah I mean that's when when you
had that conversation with your wife and
they were like hey that was kind of
childish like yeah damn you think so
like yeah I mean like because
that [__] ain't 25 28 no more like it
ain't yeah I mean [__] ain't even that
[__] ain't even it doesn't add up like
you want me to keep on standing outside
either selling drugs or holding guns
whatever the case is you know what I'm
saying like because you're not gonna be
there and don't be protected whatever it
is at 35 and keep going to jail making
and also rather than me starting a
career yeah and doing what the [__] I'm
doing and elevating like yeah I'm gonna
choose that over anything right yeah
because at the end of the day who are
who are you to your children like yeah
yeah for real who are you to your kids
that's all you should worry about like
who are you to your children as long as
you taking like these are people that
and not all of them but the people that
they want us to to be like are you going
to jail you missing out on your kids
like it's no way that you're taking care
of your kids to your full possible like
your capability if you incarcerated if
you on parole all the time if you got to
check in here you can't go here you
can't take them to this tournament out
here you can't do this you get what I'm
saying it's so many restrictions that
the streets put in your life like and I
I got uh that out my mind song where I
say I'm one foot in the game one foot
out like I'm thinking about going all in
in the blind like going legit and been
crossing my mind like I I I was just
talking about me just being in the
streets and like [__] I said the
streets Hold Me Back they've been
blocking my shine like you get what I'm
saying like at the end of the day
everything that comes to the end comes
to the end because of the street ties
and the [__] gang never gave the
legal Lane a shot ever you get what I'm
saying and and you have an opportunity
to give it a real shot so why can't a
[__] put everything into it like I put
everything into the streets because
guess what if you're one foot in one
foot out that's just gonna follow you to
wherever you're trying to get the legal
[__] together that's what I'm trying to
tell you so it's like you gotta it's not
bounce out the streets or oh disconnect
from oh I'm not from here no more or
whatever it's like I'm forever gonna be
who I am yeah you get what I'm saying
but that [__] can't control
a hundred percent of my day no more 100
like every everybody's opinion it can't
like I'm a grown-ass man you could talk
to them kids like that and try to get
them together I didn't already went
tested and approved and been through all
that little [__] right there you're not
about to try to run me through the
ringer like [__] yeah I mean
I'm not even going for that I don't even
respond like [__] man you know you
can't do that